he's great to see everybody again first
and foremost because again we spent a
lot of time with them but great to hear
their stories great to hear where they
are how things I had no idea that Damien
and Jie were back together dating I mean
it's that's that's awesome that Lauren
and Cameron got a dog or you know that
Jessica's and Kelly have had so much
self-reflection and it's just it was
really cool we asked them all to come
and that was on their choice to come
back and so to have these 10 incredible
individuals coming back for this show to
kind of speak their mind and say their
piece and and unite on this front of
what love is blind was really beautiful
and when we asked all of them would you
do it again knowing what you know now
knowing what ever you know perception is
reality in this world knowing what you
know now knowing how the show came out
knowing the hurt or the passion that you
found would you do it again all ten of
them said yes yes here you will choose
someone to marry without ever seeing
will you be my wife we didn't know if
there'd be a single proposal much less
you know six proposals and and I think
what we saw and saw very quickly were
these very genuine connections that
people were making you know sight unseen
just talking through a wall and
especially from my perspective because I
was dealing with more of the guys is
that seeing these grown men you know
like I don't to say crumbled but like I
mean really they became very unafraid to
show their emotion and be vulnerable and
I think they all would tell you they
learned a lot about themselves about
life about love from being a part of
this experiment if you will so I was
really cool for us to kind of watch all
that you know from the sidelines and be
a part of it we did get nervous like I
remember we got nervous we're like
because nobody made anybody propose let
me make that very clear this was all on
their own but once they did propose
we're like now we're gonna document all
the way to the altar and at that point
you can walk away or you can say I do
but are you gonna walk away from someone
you fell in love with and felt the need
to propose to and so I think even the
the lovers I'm gonna call them lovers
not contestants cuz that seems weird the
lovers
we're like there's no way I'm gonna find
my my partner my fiancee and then within
three days some of them six days some of
them eight days they're like oh my gosh
I don't want to lose this person and I
want I want to continue this journey
with this
and I want to marry this person that's
all real and it's really beautiful to be
part of there are definitely a lot of
moments really whoa like when we were
watching it you know I think one that's
that's that's glaring is the Carlton
diamond relationship and for us to be a
part of that on the other side and you
know you obviously didn't see a lot of
it we actually talked to every single
one of them daily so after every date we
were there in the halls talking with
them and then we would go into the men's
quarters in the women's quarters and we
would actually sit down on the couch and
have conversations like how are you
feeling what's going on not that we know
the way to do marriage of relationships
we're just a sounding board of like the
old married couple like talk to me talk
to me as somebody who's not in the pod
with you or talk to me another woman
who's not competing to find this other
guy what's going on in your mind and so
to have watch to know Carlton in to know
Diamond and to see how great they were
individually and then when they finally
came together but then have this other
layer you watched his journey of
struggling to tell her but then you also
watch the journey of her struggling to
understand it and all very quickly she's
like you've looked lived with this your
entire life and then in fact lived with
it the entire tell me that they were
courting she's like I've had one night
I've one night to kind of digest it so I
think that the beautiful thing that the
show is allowed is for everyone to
hopefully have a takeaway of how to
better communicate with other people and
empathy and have an understanding that
you never know what someone else is
going through and also not to ever take
that for granted when somebody's there
for you and wants to open up and be
vulnerable and the power of
vulnerability this is why I don't deal
with it's like you
you all call me my face I don't do what
women like you yeah yo people are coming
at her from one side which I completely
get on their end but they're getting a
piece of the puzzle so I think for her
it was just about person-to-person
understanding like something that wasn't
told to me and and trying to - Carlton's
point trying to understand it in a way
where cameras or social media aren't
involved and they are and so I think for
them it was humbling and I thought was
beautiful about today was them both
being willing to acknowledge and
recognize that they probably could have
handled it a little better you know from
both sides and and coming to some kind
of resolution that you know that you
know that was satisfactory to both of
them because you look from our
perspective when you're a part of these
people's day every week we were kind of
rooting for everybody I mean you want to
see everyone figure this out and it was
you know it kind of sucked to be honest
the way that turned out so it was nice
today to see some resolution to a couple
of the situations but especially that
way yeah
[Music]